je suis considéré comme française c'est
obligé toi dans ta tête moi dans ma tête
moi je suis je suis comme je suis
le racisme il est aussi à l'école il
touche hélas les enfants les jeunes le
moral le mouvement contre le racisme et
pour l'amitié entre les peuples diffuse
actuellement dans toute la France un
film il a interrogé les jeunes immigrés
ses enfants qui sont nés deux parents
émigrés mais sur le sol français des
inquiétudes mais aussi souvent des
réactions savoureuses regardez
Christine j'ai 20 ans
Italie à Naples et Jeannette est-ce que
tu es je suis sénégalaise je suis né à
Marseille je viens de Toulouse
en réparant son espagnol mais pense on
est au Vietnam
Turquie ça fait 10 ans qu'on habite là
Vanessa où est-ce que tu es né
en France depuis 15 ans
[Musique]
je me sens
française Marseillaise et puis
algérienne étrangère
je me sens tout à la fois
je suis intégré à la France je suis
français je suis clairement faire parce
qu'autre chose
et les gens comment ils te sentent
un peu étrangère
avec les papiers je suis français oui
mais pas avec ma tête princesse
parce que c'est un pays d'adoption
c'est obligé
moi je suis je suis comme je suis
comment
[Musique]
en quoi
premièrement je parle pas l'arabe du
tout et puis je suis né ici quand même
si les gens qui habitent ici me disent
que fait comme chez toi bah je me
sentirai comme chez moi
est-ce que un copain français un copain
comme toi qui vient du Maghreb c'est
différent non pour moi il y a pas de
différence quoi il a de neige
les copains français quand on va en
boîte dans une discothèque quelconque la
région du Nord ou Nord-Pas-de-Calais
quand un océro foulé personne ne rentre
voilà
[Musique]
est-ce que toi tu as déjà rencontré le
racisme ça m'est arrivé où j'ai demandé
du travail on m'a demandé par téléphone
on m'a demandé comment tu t'appelais
un logement j'en ai vu pas mal de
propriétaires et la plupart d'entre eux
ils acceptent pas les gens de couleur et
plus difficile sur le travail
du chômage
je parle du racisme beaucoup
la drogue
faut pas laisser passer
tout le monde on vit en communauté et je
trouve que il faut agir
[Musique]